es war ein zähes ringen aber am ende
rauften sich die eu-staaten schließlich
zusammen und einigten sich im streit um
das geplante öl-embargo gegen russland
auf einen kompromiss beim gipfeltreffen
in brüssel verkündet
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
vergangene nacht die
froh dass sich die europäischen
staatschefs letzten acht auf sechs
sanktionen gegen russland einigen
konnten das war ein sehr wichtiger
schritt nach vorne in die eu sollte nun
in der lage sein ein embargo zu
verhängen das betrifft rund 90 prozent
der russischen öl importe bis jahresende
und waffenlieferungen aus deutschland in
die ukraine schwierig bis gar nicht und
wenn dann nur im absoluten
schneckentempo deshalb helfen die
ukraine sich jetzt mit waffen vom feind
wie unser kollege björn stritzel im don
was miterlebt hat
massiver dauerbeschuss der russischen
armee zermürbt die ukrainische linien im
osten die ukraine bietet seit wochen um
unterstützung um schwere waffen auch
deutschland kündigt lieferungen in
großem umfang an doch die wahrheit ist
die bedrängte ukraine bekommt aus berlin
fast nur militärisches kleines gerät
gebhard flaig panzer auch nach monaten
nicht da ausreichend munition wird noch
gesucht von der panzerhaubitze 2000
keine spur ein sieg über die russische
übermacht scheinbar aussichtslos und
trotzdem der siegeswille der ukraine
ungebrochen und not macht erfinderisch
ukrainische artillerieeinheiten in einem
waldgebiet nahe der besetzten stadt easy
um beladen mit raketenwerfern vom typ b
m 21
vollgeladen mit je 40 grad raketen
waffen der russen erkämpft im gefecht
der kampf gegen die russin wird mit
russischen waffen geführt
wir sind in der ost ukraine wo russische
truppen in den vergangenen wochen die
ukrainischen verteidiger in die
defensive gezwungen haben vor allem
aufgrund ihrer überlegenen raketen
artillerie die russischen truppen haben
einfach viel mehr gerät haben viel mehr
munition für ihre raketen werfer systeme
und hinter mir sehen wir jetzt ein wm 21
grad schon einige jahrzehnte alt
mehrfach raketenwerfersystem und das
besondere an diesem gerät hinter mir ist
das hat es vor einigen tagen noch dem
der russischen armee gehört ukrainische
truppen konnten es erbeuten haben es
wieder instand gesetzt und es wird jetzt
gleich eingesetzt um damit auf russische
stellungen zu feuern wir können uns auch
noch mal anschauen dieses system kann
das mal zeigen wie alt das tatsächlich
ist wir sehen es auch an den reifen die
reifen sind noch
hergestellt wurden in der sowjetunion
die drei meter langen raketen können
knapp 20 kilometer weit verschossen
werden der gefechtskopf wie gut 20
kilogramm mit einem höllenlärm rasen die
raketen im halb sekundentakt aus den
rohren innerhalb weniger sekunden sind
jeweils 20 raketen verschossen die zeit
drängt doch die waffenlieferungen aus
deutschland bleiben aus
ja und dann wendet sich wolodimir
selensky in der nacht noch mit einem
ganz dramatischen appell an die menschen
denn es droht so der ukrainische
präsident eine weltweite hungersnot
aufgrund der weizen blockade
weil die russen unseren zugang zum
schwarzen meer blockieren können wir 22
millionen tonnen weizen aus unseren
lagern nicht exportieren russische
blockade die stabilisiert die weltweite
situation dermaßen dass die preise für
nahrungsmittel dramatisch steigen werden
die folge werden hungersnöte in afrika
asien und teilen europas sein